So what sort of things do you think we can do to improve this graph?
>> So if we we're doing 100% of data I think a cool and
youthful way often to show data is by using a stacked barchart.
And so you can still show 100% of the data.
So in this graph for example we're looking at the population of
New York over time and it let's you see changes.
For example here you can see the green space,
which represents Manhattan, changes from being.
What is this?
83% of the population.
And then drastically reduces over time.
And so you can still make a, a meaningful comparison.
In fact, I think more meaningful because it's showing 100% side by side.
And it's a lot easier to, to take in the distribution of that.
In a line and in a stack bar chart type format then it would in a pie chart.